[Music]
the new season of stranger things drops
on July 4th and it's been over a year
since we've heard from 11 Mike and the
rest of the gang we don't know much
about what they'll be up to for season 3
but we know one thing's for sure Hawkins
is getting a mall today Hawkins is
taking another step into the future with
the brand-new star court wall Netflix
tees the return of the show last year
with a glorious and nostalgic mock
commercial for the opening of the star
Court mall for a show steeped in 80's
culture the opening of a brand new mall
seems about right
but these days moles look a lot less
like this and more like this according
to one analysis roughly a quarter of
u.s. malls will close by 2022 so how did
we get here and can dead malls find new
life to find out we spoke with Ellen
Dunham Jones a professor of architecture
and urban design at Georgia Tech my name
is Ellen dum Jones and I study how to
retrofit suburbia
so the third season of stranger things
is set in 1985 and clearly malls are
gonna play a big role in the show
what role did malls play in America in
the 80s malls played an enormous role
they really became the place to go I
think the role of malls in our culture
was especially important for teenagers
they were shopping for an identity
because suddenly you had this homogenous
Asian it's level it's all chain stores
it's not some unique little boutique on
a main mom-and-pop shop in your
community they're selling the same
clothes that the TV shows are showing
and it was a little bit of a pre-chewed
identity that later generations suddenly
said that's really boring and the last
thing on earth that some of us want but
at the in the 80s it was pretty big so
Ellen you were just mentioning that the
malls when they grew to be so popular
especially with teen culture they really
disrupted the mom-and-pop stores in
downtown's
and actually in the trailer for stranger
things season 3 there's there's a scene
where you can see people holding protest
signs and I wonder if you could speak a
little bit to the effect that suburban
malls really had on the Centers of
cities and on mom-and-pop stores the
story between the cities and the suburbs
is a pretty long story the heyday of the
cities with the image of the big
bustling metropolis is really the 20s
the 1930s the depression hits
everybody's pretty flat the 40s were at
war World War two by the time the
veterans come back from World War two
the cities have not been invested in in
over 20 years and so the the way to
kick-start the economy was let's build
suburbia and give everybody brand-new
fresh homes through the 50s through the
60s through the 70s 80s 90s the cities
were really not invested in so all the
money all the infrastructure all the
private development it was all going out
to the suburbs and malls were just very
much a part of that the 90s has been
mall development starts to slow down and
then it comes to a big halt by the mid
2000s and cities start to actually
become invested in again we see a lot of
those little mom-and-pop sand main
streets coming back with more local
shopping and more local identities let's
talk about all of these empty malls
how many have closed how many more are
closing in general it's safe to say that
there are 1500 properties in the US that
at one time have been an enclosed
shopping mall we're now down to a little
under a thousand so we've lost fully a
third of our malls a lot of people say
well we'll probably lose another quarter
about 250 I look at just in my database
all of the proposals to redevelop re
inhabit these properties I've got over
450 that I'm tracking and so that tells
me that there's more likely about a
third of those malls not being
clothes shopping malls much longer in a
pretty short period of time
there are several YouTube channels I
noticed that are devoted to kind of
being obsessed with dead malls and it
reminded me of like the ruin porn when
Detroit had gone bankrupt and everyone
was obsessed with looking at the old
abandoned buildings what what's going on
with that what is our cultural obsession
with you know vacancy and death I mean I
think there's always been the three-song
of the abandoned and the sublime is a
its own form of terror and beauty that
was that goes back to the the romantics
in the nineteenth century wrote about
you know standing on a glacier looking
at the tip of the iceberg and feeling
feeling small relative to the rest of it
but the romantics when they were looking
at that glacier I love them and I
studied them part of the feeling of that
sublimity was that they were like this
glacier could crush and kill me and yet
I survived so is that how we feel that
like capitalism and death could come for
I exactly I mean if the mall could
collapse oh my god
you know just in that it's the end of
the world what is going on why what what
is responsible for the fall of the mall
newspapers like to jump to that the
headline oh it's online shopping it's
the more like the nail in the coffin
than it really is the beginning the the
decline of malls really starts in the
90s mostly because we built so many of
them they began to cannibalize each
other so you start to get to some re a
lot of repositioning of malls as they're
kind of evolving into new things if
they're in a good market if they're in a
weak market though you started to see a
lot of mall owners just simply default
on their loans
it's the shifting of jobs and shifting
of wealth it's also just demographics
suburbia was always built on the
assumption that it's kind of your
building mostly starter homes for new
young families today there are half as
many households with kids that there
were in the 70s
part of the decline of malls also due to
the fact that now we spend that time
gathering online absolutely I mean I
think that there's a lot
if that social function is being
substituted with online the former
Surgeon General declared that the u.s.
is in a loneliness epidemic and much of
this he blamed on substituting social
media for really being in social spaces
the reality is the moles they are
gathering spaces but still generally you
have to be spending at least some money
to be able to hang out there but they
certainly did serve that function for
generations
absolutely what are these malls that
that fail turning into and being
redeveloped as all sorts of things and
it depends a lot on the market there are
folks who are able to sort of revive a
dead mall with just new retail and
throwing in a lot more restaurants what
I'm really interested in are where folks
are looking at the death of this
property as an opportunity to help a
twentieth-century suburb address 21st
century problems so a big chunk of them
are being redeveloped as really the
downtown that suburb never had so
they're tearing down most of them all
putting in a street grid ground level
retail apartments and offices up above
they're becoming more like cities but
that only works where there's a strong
market where the jobs have gone away or
where population is stagnant and/or
shrinking which is a lot of the country
then often what happens is the malls are
getting Rhian habited with more
community serving uses the most common
is actually just to become office space
other reuses are either as for medical
uses lots of educational uses and lots
of churches lots of religious groups
going at taking over malls the third
group of them are the rege readings now
that those properties are dying it's a
great opportunity to actually deep pave
these places reconstruct the wetlands
put in community gardens parks that then
increases the value of the properties
adjacent to them and triggers some
redevelopment so they're actually there
are quite a few entrepreneurs so
have figured out how to tap into the
apocalyptic imagery of the dead mall so
there's a quite a number of malls that
while they're sitting there dead they
offer paintball zombies in a mall
outside of London you're given the
paintball and you try to shoot the
zombies who are professional actors and
there's a whole script that goes along
and you don't really know so okay that
nursing unit over there are they there
to protect me or are they going to
infect me so I become a zombie it's it's
amazing what people will come up with
Wow so these dead malls in some ways are
like a living metaphor and then we can
sort of in inhabit them in ways that
terrify and scare us and like tap into
something which maybe is what stranger
things is probably planning to do I mean
I imagine that they're gonna play up
then the stall juh of the malls and then
terrify us inside the mall okay well
Ellen this has been so lovely thank you
so much for your time and this has been
fascinating I hope you get a chance to
watch season 3 oh my pleasure
absolutely